ma belli da casa come state ciao ragazzi
allora come state voluto fare questa
live perché mi hanno sfrattato da casa
mia
e adesso io vivo vivo qua vivo qua e
faccio i miei video blog qua e spero che
questo sia un posto adeguato per fare
gli unboxing vedete ho già scartato
tutti i vostri pacchi grazie che mi
avete lanciato tutti questi pacchi che
siete stati fantastici e niente io
adesso in avanti vivo vivo qui questa è
questo il mio letto no party scalzi
comunque siamo abbiamo appena finito di
fare le riprese di un videoclip per pre
gabry ponte che non so se vi possiamo
sperare cosa ma abbiamo fatto una cosa
della madonna che ci sono due miliardi
di cameo tipo cioè ben difficilmente
fede mette bizet
non mettetevi se non ci sono che cazzo
dicono che va beh insomma in questo
video
io mi devo limonare con giulia penna che
una ragazza una ragazza ho dovuto fare
questa cosa io mi vergogno e infatti poi
è stato molto difficile però abbiamo
registrato su videoclip per gabry ponte
che sarebbe seguito di che ne sanno i
duemila un'altra canzone sarebbe che
usciva molto più avanti vabbè comunque è
una figata vabbè adesso stiamo tornando
a casa
questo era e questa era la base del come
si dice
era la base del set dove dove abbiamo
girato appunto il video quindi quando
tornavamo a vestirci se non eravamo su
stroke amp e adesso niente siamo rimasti
io e giulia
un nostro amico che adesso ci accompagni
a casa e vi faccio fare un bel tour del
camper così perché mi va siete dei
commenti e sempre pieno che non vedo un
cazzo sono nascondiglio perfetto
permesso grazie a salve stasera ci sono
tipo 20mila persone che mi stanno
guardando il mostro qualcosa è il vostro
momento di risplendere di te un qualcosa
di serio
spendiamo tantissimo perfetto di uno
splendido splendente perfetto grandi
complimenti avete reso l'idea
bene allora qualche dove cuciniamo
questo è il banco praticamente sì chi è
che fa sembrare io faccio a esemplari
faccio una donna come si chiama quella
che frangetta la frangetta donna ma è
non lo so chi sta intendendo quella che
porta a dover dosi poi eccolo non
spariamo delinquente questi non hanno
visto breaking bad
no non avete se non muore nessuno skyler
non si fa trombato bene allora volevo
dirvi questo è il camper dove questa era
la base qua c truccavano io sono anche
insultato in questo momento pensate che
poca mascolinità che già ne avevo poca
prima figuriamoci adesso è comunque cosa
in mano al piano però mi sta affacciando
della a non potete vedere questa loro
ragazzi non potete vedere
vabbè no niente la rischio ecco il fatto
che siamo stati a registrare io e la
giulietta ma che possiamo andare vai tra
andiamo quindi tanto io vado in live
artisti sempre abbiamo registrato io e
la giulietta in mezzo alla pioggia al
freddo e al gelo ed intemperie
ecco infatti sono due giorni che ci
stiamo in botte almeno io ho pure tu che
fai ci sarà imbottendo di sembra uno
sponsor alla medicina che non ho mai
preso in vita mia ma non è uno sponsor
io per far per dire che poi non è uno
sponsor per dar nella prova devo dire
che fa cagare è una me è una merda non è
un non è uno spot pro mi veramente ci
stiamo imbottendo di scarola perché
con due tre giorni che giriamo al freddo
e nulla comunque sia io già sfoderato
che abbiamo fatto le cose sporche e
quindi ho dovuto dire dai allora potevo
click day tare sta live e scrivere o
limonato non lo so giulia penna per dire
per un click paint della madonna non lo
fa click click the bay jabal di click di
beit le acli kbyte quando uno youtuber
altrimenti faccio l'esempio chi pestato
un piede per strada mentre stai
bloccando il titolo è sono quasi morto
quello è un click bait capito secondo
tue enfatizzi una cosa che non è quella
cioè non so come viene vista in
generazione tipo limonato in laiche e
vero però è per attirare visto e capito
che qui non so farlo sarebbe dovuto
scrivere o limonata secondo giusta ce
l'ha stupita errori ma anche tattico
titoli ta in quella roba lì e non ci stà
riduca cesta megan fox a quest ora
problema è che non so fare click day
quindi niente ho scritto che cucinano
che cazzo scritto nel titolo mi ricordo
niente comunque abbiamo certo non i due
è di pippa di cosa allora ci hanno
chiesto di darci dei tanti tanti baci
nel video è adesso ci penso che è stato
reso noto difendere e già sta dicendo il
live si mai si è finto barca va oggi la
verità band è brutto no la valigia
quanto è brutto aveva dice in camper
madonna
come se i street e l'hotel vittimistica
ma penso a me allora nessuno perché nel
calcio della valigia adesso tutti
vogliono sapere adesso che ti mette in
primo piano
così tutti vogliono sapere che cosa si
prova a limonare fa vj by però io non
c'entro niente
penso che questo l'effetto che faccia le
donne grazie a guardarli può vedere è
stata veramente tragico con questa porta
quasi sta chiedendo riaprendo villette
un'ansia ordiniamo la giovane che aiuti
a port au prince
mi cucini un toast già che ci sei dai
baci il bacio sono sia andato quindi è
vicina ma per ragazzi comunque è
successo questo no no grazie non lo bevo
e niente volevo un po aggiornarvi sulla
situazione non va in grazia a posto se
riuscite ad utilizzare trasmetti svetta
scritto atleta sono un fenomeno sul gay
combattuto ma riusciti facendo questa
non mi sa che ti hanno fatto gli hanno
fatto vincere prima che al tate i maghi
alla chicca che lui mirata non ti sta
dicendo niente ma incazzati fico ragalna
chi il camper lasciamo perdere e niente
di aggiornato un attimo sulla situa la
ga e niente stiamo tornando a casa io ho
montato il video di stamattina in un'ora
praticamente un record
reale sono 23 nostro due giorni che sono
sul set già dalla mattina anche lei e
quindi abbiamo fatto una levataccia per
un paio di giorni però abbia finito in
video uscirà tra un mese e spero che vi
piaccia
tra un mese perché è pieno zeppo di
effetti speciali
c'è veramente chi in terapia può
accompagnare so nulla raga stato il mio
uscito scritto connessione pessima
quindi che se la juve deve finire prima
possibile giulia ma ce l'ho mai tenere
la valigia fermo una da me la tengo io
sono io l'uomo all'uomo di kata vengo io
ecco no perché
no perché tutti mi state mandando le
foto di me e di lei e di mette pisa e
benji e fede che siamo insieme ed è
quello il motivo minchia non potevo
dirvelo ma secondo me io questo video
non lo facevo fare io non potevo dire
queste cose le ho dette lochte è colpa
tua
ragazzi non sta non questo video dove
cancellare perché mi sa che ho detto
tante di quelle cose che non potevo
assoluta ormai l'ho detto e vabbè
pazienza loro già lo sapevano è allora
pensiamo alle cose serie
la luna di miele dove la vuoi fa
vabbè allora alle maldive siamo a
gennaio il cpm palco andrà a londra sono
già stato no io no vi rendete conto il
gran e cioè io non porto la ragazza a
londra hanno comunque visto che tra
tutti i video di just dance dove ballo
in modo sensuale alla fine è servito
rimorchiare cioè ecco quindi che mi ha
fatto uno stacchetto stile rimorchiata
di tagliando così è bastato questo e lo
rivoltato no niente raga quindi
non mandatemi più foto di vice il fatto
che non fatte con tutti bene fede perché
ci sarà il video della madonna che
uscirà tra un mese e io ho spoilerato
turno che aprì ponte mi ammazzerà
scusami capri che stai guardando questo
video di
duro non volevo farlo ma mi andava di
fan alive quindi l'ho fatta
racconti che domanda e passaggi e che
altri e tra l'altro ragazzi non so se
conoscete capri ponte perché vale gap
rimonta fatta una canzone che si chiama
giardino della canzone fa impiccheranno
jordi con una corda d'oro ok è un
privilegio raro però per continuare il
testo di una canzone è una canzone
famosissima se non la conoscete
grazie grazie grazie dei rumori di fondo
vorrei impiccheranno jordi con una corda
d'oro e io ho chiesto a gabry ponte
capri ma alla fine jordi hanno impiccato
no e non mi ha più parlato
ma non mi ha più parlato da quel momento
e lo capisco pecorino dai basta cagate
io volevo fare questa live per
aggiornabile la situa dei pai vito nel
mentre ragazza che c'è ora che capita io
vi saluto in mano un bacio ryan
buonanotte
ci sentiamo presto lasciato lasciare un
commento non mi piace anche vari social
che come vi do the dark iniziare i
lavori si scateni ci vediamo in un
prossimo camper si spera da ragazzi